want to share one more story with you
this morning because it is a wonderful
symbol
of the sign of our times we've talked
often about the exodus from california
specifically to places like texas
companies moving from california to
texas and people moving from california
to texas
perhaps this is the perfect symbol for
the first time since 1942
the rose bowl will move from california
to texas coveted restrictions will not
allow
fans to be there not allow contact
sports in northern california
but so many restrictions in california
that it will be moving to
dallas this is what bill hancock the
college football playoff executive
director because the rose bowl is
part of the college football semifinals
this year the game
in dallas will still be played in the
mid-afternoon window on new year's day
we are pleased that parents and loved
ones will now be able to see their
students
play in the game there's only two things
i think about when i think of the rose
bowl
traditionally big ten championship and
pasadena california i don't even know
where pasadena is
all i know is the rose bowl is there not
big ten championship big ten versus
pac-10
12 champions meet at the rose bowl
correct man
shame on me that's all right i'm not
trying i'm not trying to slam dunk
sports knowledge and will does slam dunk
in my face
posterizing me right here on fox and
he's right to do so
but just like the orange county uh
california republicans
are right to point this out he said yet
another california tradition
leaving for texas thanks to gavin
newsom games like this on you know
apparently you can get it done
in texas but in california these kinds
of shutdowns
well you got to make a choice you got to
play it somewhere it'll be in texas
jerry world in dallas